I saw there was a property networking
event went in got paid by
£3,000 and then a guy came over and said
have you paid for this event and I was
like um Oh I thought it was I thought it
was free you just wanted to check you
were part of the event I thought it was
a free networking event I I just
something's not right so I'd obviously
like to leave I think you're
bullshitting so what do you want me to
do tell me the truth be a man I'm
staying here I came to the reception and
they told me there was a property event
something doesn't feel right about this
whole situation so if you're not going
to be honest with me about it's
conversation isn't it after the event
organizers had repeatedly asked me to
leave I recognized someone at the door
at my last ditch attempt at getting back
in the
room oh my goodness oh my
goodness could I get a selfie with you
is that okay I'm a massive
fan you keep nice and quiet boy nice to
see
you